hey guys it's Friday and it's time for
another movie retrospective and on this
one we're doing another double feature
and we're finally getting around to
doing probably some of the most classic
sci-fi horror films ever made
alien and aliens yeah they're both
masterpieces of what they are you know
first ones kind of a horror movie in a
sci-fi setting the other one is an
action movie in a sci-fi setting but to
a prize to a probably most greatest
flicks of all times oh definitely I'm
not you're not gonna get any argument
for me now we also did Prometheus and
alien covenant on one show yeah
obviously these are way better and you
know than those even though I like both
of those movies but these two were kind
of like the gold standard
we're probably are we even gonna do an
episode on three and four no really
francelina
three and four almost like fanfiction
yeah when you're compared to these four
films right here because you to me it's
obvious that alien one and to Prometheus
and covenant are in the same series yeah
three and four kind of seem kind of like
fanfiction to me three isn't terrible
it's actually the tone is pretty good
for to me is almost kind of like a
cartoon movie there's a lot of
cartoonish elements to it it's almost
kind of like soldier really with with
Kurt Russell yeah it kind of feels like
that but you said that these two I think
that they are better than alien and
covenant that it sees me then Prometheus
and covenant but Prometheus and Covenant
visually they they hit high marks I
think they look great oh yeah the acting
isn't bad the storytelling isn't bad
it's just that a lot of it's missing it
was cut out nothing I had had a lot to
do with the you know stuff that was
happening with the studios yeah they
wanted the movies to be shorter and they
wanted it to be more like alien and it's
hard to take Prometheus and covenant and
cut it down into into a movie that kind
of Apes alien - I think that's what the
fans wanted yeah that's not what Ridley
Scott wanted though so but still you
know I respect all four of the movies
really
and they're all I mean obviously like
you said you know three and four
notwithstanding you know those ones are
the four that we've talked about that
we're gonna talk about today that we
talked about before are obviously all in
the same mythos whereas like the other
two we're almost like offshoot it's
almost kind of consider them in the same
vein as like alien versus Predator
movies which are you know nominally in
the same universe but not really
yeah locked in uation a lot of people
dump on the AVP movies I actually
enjoyed them I think they're fun to
watch I like them both I like them both
even though even though Requiem is kind
of dark I like people complain that you
well I think it's probably better dark
because the special effects probably
sucked and if you saw him clearly they
wouldn't be any good better not probably
yeah sometimes that works in a baby's
yeah yeah especially if it's like a
horror movie it's like oh I can barely
see it my imagination makes it way more
scary I thought rec room was fun I think
but you know a lot of hardcore fans
especially younger guys in their 20s
they love the nitpick stuff you know and
I think they had their hopes set on a
movie of a higher caliber so I think
they saw it as kind of like a wasted
opportunity me I just saw it as kind of
like bonus fan fiction you know that's
yeah that's probably a good way look
that's how I look at it you know it's
just is better than no movie at all yeah
but we're getting off the subject let's
go ahead and get to alien one yeah let's
talk about alien one which came out in
1979 yeah and I saw it with my dad in
the theaters back when I was about nine
and I saw it at least twice the movie
was badass it was kind of like 2001 it
was like an homage to 2001 but it was a
horror movie and man it just stood head
and shoulders above all the competition
in those days I mean it really put you
in there
it put you in that movie you felt like
you were really there that's really some
and this is what amazes me okay the the
original script of alien was written by
Dan O'Bannon and Ronald Shusett now they
they have both said it's like we kind of
stole from everything we stole from
thing from another world they stole from
like some be science fiction movies like
if you've seen the Mystery Science
Theater episode Knight of the blood
beast from 1958 and that also has an
astronaut that comes back to earth and
he's been impregnated by an alien
there's like little alien shrimp to
something so it's like he got ideas from
like a bunch of different places and
obviously the Star Wars and things like
that now at first this was gonna be a
low-budget movie like a low-budget
sci-fi type of movie but after the
success of Star Wars and stuff like
bigger you know Studios started taking
interest in sci-fi and you know we're
willing to throw more money at it so you
know so they got their script bought by
a subsidiary 20th Century Fox and then
there were three people from from the
subsidiary who wanted to go over the
script and actually generally rewrote it
now Dan O'Bannon was not happy about
that but it should be noted that the
three guys that did all the script
rewrites and stuff that were from the
that were from the whatcha call it they
were the ones that came up with the
whole subplot about ash the science
officer that was all their idea which
was actually a very good addition to the
movie I thought because it gave it a lot
more suspense and [ __ ] like that so yeah
and a lot of mystery because you know ya
give a backstory of like hey why did
this guy show up mysteriously before
right right put him on the crew before
the mission started yeah they're already
setting you up you know they're you know
Scott is telling you that finding this
alien craft was no accident
yeah the company knew it was there right
and the interesting thing too this was
only and actually Ridley Scott was not
the first director that was pegged to do
this initially he was not interested in
doing it because he was just like man
but you know and actually but when he
ended up doing this this was only his
second movie which is an amazing amazing
I didn't even know that he had made one
movie before the duelists in 1977 cuz
only yes this was only his second movie
now Sigourney Weaver she was I think
this was really her first major role she
had only done Broadway previous to this
the cool thing about this movie and Dan
O'Bannon has said that when he wrote the
original script he's like every single
part was unisex he didn't really care if
they cast men or women in the roles it
didn't make any difference
so the
state director once the movie was put
into production had a lot of leeway as
to which you know who we wanted to cast
in whatever role and the interesting
thing about it is that pretty much all
of the actors in this were much older
than actors that would normally be in
this type of movie that would be in like
a sci-fi or a horror type of movie and I
think that actually really helped I mean
Sigourney Weaver was the youngest and
she was 29 so you know all the other
ones you know Harry Dean Stanton and you
know all the other ones were much older
they were all good actors in it today
that cast it made you really feel like
these were real people especially the
way they were interacting with each
other you know what I mean and a lot of
that a lot of that dialogue sounded like
it was ad libbed around the the dining
room table you know yeah and fantastic
characters they really drew you into the
story and I think that's probably I mean
other than the amazing alien design
obviously which you don't see a lot of
in the first movie because the first
movie is very much yes it has sci-fi
elements but I mean pretty much it's a
straight-up
horror movie like a suspense horror
movie um you know other than the
creature design which of course was
amazing and still looks amazing now and
I really don't think it's been topped it
hasn't even come close to being topped
in all the years since but I think my
favorite thing about this is the
characterization I mean the moment that
you get put on this ship I mean the ship
obviously looks like a ship that's been
used that's been lived in and then you
get these people waking up and they're
just shooting the [ __ ] with one another
and it's like you can tell these are
just like working-class folks and
they're just like yeah we're on our way
back to earth you know tone or and you
know they're very relatable they're very
likeable and I really like how Ridley
Scott established all their characters
like immediately and it seemed like so
organic and I think that that was one
thing that made this movie so much
scarier because you felt like you were
there with them because ya felt like
normal regular people just doin their
job and then all of a sudden these
horrible things happen especially
especially in context with 1979 because
the United States at that time was
still kind of like an industrial
superpower and if you were there in that
movie theater watching the movie chances
are you worked for a pretty big company
maybe you worked you know and I'm some
kind of mining company or an oil company
or are stealing cars building buildings
and you know when my dad took me in 79
what I'm seeing on the screen is the
exam civilization I'm a part of as a kid
it's just that it's us in space yeah you
know so the people in the audience who
are watching this move you're very much
like the people in the crew you know and
then when I can remember as a kid you
know just the reactions of the audience
you know the people that were with me
just I can just remember how each one of
those characters affected the audience
and each one of them kind of had their
own role in the movie like Parker you
know a lot of guys remember Parker
Parker was the black guy who ran the the
mechanic stuff that you know he was like
and listen engineer he's like an
engineer down there
he wanted more money Nate you know he
thought the executives were kind of
cheating him out of a whole Sheri didn't
if he didn't agree to a half a share he
agreed to a half a share but he had no
choice but agreed to a half a share well
that particular character really was
kind of like the audience's umbilical
cord into this movie because he was
working class in the same way that the
audience tended to be kind of
working-class and I really liked that
character I remembered how much the
audience responded to Parker
yeah Parker was kind of like the
everyman in this story and he actually
he has a lot of victories a lot of
triumphs and he goes down he goes down
fight the great thing about Parker as a
character is that you know he's funny
and relatable from the beginning but
he's like hey I'm just doing a job but
you know I don't get paid enough for
this [ __ ] you know when they have to go
check out the you know the distress
signal because it's in there attracting
blonde blonde he's like I'm not paying
enough to do this crap and stuff but
then as the movie goes on and the [ __ ]
starts hitting the fan he really steps
up and you know saves people's lives and
things like that so a lot of average
people feel that the executive level
kind or that there that they don't
really deserve the positions that
they're in that there isn't a really
other than a some paperwork and maybe
going to the right schools that doesn't
necessarily mean that they're more
competent than you are
yeah it's almost you know it's funny
because like one of the executives gets
up from his chair when Parker sits in it
he brushes it off before he sits it down
kind of like they're dirty you know it's
funny you know that's funny and people
could relate to it it's good yeah
and he's actually making the right calls
a lot of times yeah like hey why don't
you freeze him
why don't they freeze him well there's
ulterior motives that's why they don't
freeze him but you know he's he's making
the the the logical call that the
average man would you know who's in the
audience what they would be thinking you
know freeze him ya know and I mean
really Parker's character and Ripley
played by Sigourney Weaver are really
the only two characters that are doing
things the way they're supposed to be
done or like following protocol I mean
he's like hey you know she was the one
that when John Hurt's character Cain
gets brought back with the [ __ ] face
hugger and he's like she's like you guys
can't come in here it's like you're
gonna infect the whole ship yet you know
yes I like you guys but you know I don't
want all of us to get killed and then
even the captain Dallas like overrides
her right but you know her and Parker
pretty much the only ones that are going
by the book everybody else you know as
as sympathetic is all of the characters
I mean up the only unsympathetic
character really is ash and you find out
why later on yeah well one of the things
to happen you remember um Dallas kind of
turned on Ripley hey you almost led us
out there you know what yeah the
quarantine but to the quarantine and and
porkin goes well hey maybe there's
something to that
yeah maybe there's something to that you
know so Parker was one of the only guys
have a real only person of the crew that
backed Ripley up yeah because she was
right yeah now he also he does a lot of
cool stuff he actually saves Ripley's
life her saves her from the robot yeah
feats the robot and then he goes down
fighting the alien itself to defend uh
what was her name
yeah it goes down lab
that's what her name was he goes down
defendant Lambert no Parker in many ways
is kind of like a parallel with Hicks
that are very much kind of like the same
character and in a way they're both
every man's that kind of pull you into
the story they both have their own
tribes and then they both fall usually
they die trying to save a woman which is
kind of a I guess you could say it's the
trope but they're good characters I kind
of see Parker as the prototype for Hicks
yeah the cool thing about this and that
kind of relates a little bit to what
you're just saying but the interesting
thing and I'm not the only person that's
noticed this obviously every critic has
noticed this every you know everyone
that's talked about alien and aliens has
noticed that the the alien itself and
the lifecycle of the alien which I
should say you know that creature
designed by H R Giger or Geiger I've
heard it pronounced both ways has never
been topped as I said they wanted that
particular look because of its sexual
connotations because its head is very
phallic and various other things and Dan
O'Bannon has specifically said when he
wrote the screenplay he's like you know
I wanted to kind of subvert the regular
horror movie sci-fi trope of like women
being penetrated or victimized by you
know by man by being stabbed or by being
raped or whatever he's like by doing it
to a man because I thought that would
make everyone very uncomfortable he's
like so I had these very vaginal or very
and very phallic looking aliens that
were like you know getting onto a dudes
face and like putting things inside his
body and then having them bust out and
he's like and I and I definitely wanted
to make he's like you know you know
everyone had seen it done to women over
and over but he's like I thought it
would be much more upsetting to see that
done to a man before he was his bodily
violation and all this other kind of
stuff yes funny because they come up
with these crazy ideas but the audiences
the audience's don't see him I mean I
was 9 at the time and I was with my dad
watching these movies and I don't recall
anybody from the time ever
having any kind of sexual connotation
with this movie you know I mean they
just saw it as alien sinon I mean yeah
aliens putting it laying eggs into you
and stuff you know like a parasite yeah
but that was something that they want
and that's kind of why they liked HR
Giger's creature design because oh his
work is very very sexual very
biomechanical and all his creatures are
a phallic they're very vaginal
Lovecraftian really yeah and actually a
the first alien movie has been called
the greatest Lovecraft adaptation that
actually wasn't based on a Lovecraft
Tori because you know it is very
visually it is it does look very crafty
and I can see where they're coming from
but I remember the people of the time I
think that was kind of escaped them I
think that was a little you know I mean
they weren't thinking along those lines
they just saw yeah no I mean but yeah
critics did but you know the everything
the the time was different back then you
know there was no internet people went
to go see movies and then they didn't
read reviews and then most of them
didn't read any magazines about it
afterwards there wasn't like a fanfic
after-market really in those days of the
maybe Fangoria magazine and things
people just saw movies and took them for
what they were and read into them you
know what what they thought and I
remember you know being nine seeing this
happen to me it was just a lian's alien
monsters that lay that laid eggs do you
into you kind of like the way a wasp
would put an egg into it that's what
they based it on yeah okay Angela yeah
and things that you saw bugs do he and I
really didn't stand out to me in 79 it's
being anything sexual but like I said it
was only 9 yeah but the thing is not
being nine years old in 1979 you're
exposed to sex yeah I mean you know it
was all it was everywhere you know
people think that the the the the good
old days were super puritanical no not
at all the 70s was wild I was in
California at the time you know I mean
it was nothing to go to the go to the
beach and go to the mountains and see
teenage girls walk around absolutely
naked because there was nudism and stuff
going on yeah so you know it was just
and you know the California hot tub
culture and [ __ ] you know we you know
even as a kid you knew what was going on
yeah yeah the 70s were just in a while
yeah was if you weren't there but yeah I
was in I do remember
was in the heart of it Long Beach
California yeah but yeah so like another
thing I wanted to talk about a little
bit with the first alien before we move
on to the second one is that we have the
blu-ray which has the theatrical cut and
it also has the director's cut
now the director's cut I actually like a
bit better even though not a shit-ton
has been added to it the two major
things that have been added are two
scenes both of which I really like
now if you saw the theatrical version
you know everybody that gets killed like
you know the captain and everyone that
gets killed over the course of the movie
in the theatrical version you never find
out what happened to them or where they
went
in the director's cut you do there is
one rather brief scene where you where
you see where the bodies have gone and
you know ripley destroying them also the
other scene that was added which I
[ __ ] love was actually the first
glimpse of the alien but the way it was
done was so awesome it's it's when Brett
is going looking for Jones the cat and
he goes into that big warehouse a type
of thing and then he kind of looks like
hangar and lets the water like drip on
his face and you see the alien like
hanging from the but what doesn't
he doesn't notice it if he doesn't
notice it and it doesn't like it's not a
big deal like they're not like Junta or
anything they're just showing it and
actually you're not really sure because
there's chains and it's dark and so wait
is that the alien like you hanging out
there like you're not even sure and I
kind of love that they introduced it
that way and that the a triple cut so I
actually really like because you know
then later on you see like the turns
around he sees his face it's like oh you
know I mean but some guy and I really
like the scene where it shows you what
happened to the missing crew yeah I
liked that they were kind of being
digested and transformed into these eggs
big the same kind they're being cocooned
like as hosts right well they're turned
into eggs they have a face hugger in it
yeah now some some purists are like you
know some fans this movie might say hey
hold on only a queen can lay eggs but
actually there's a lot of precedence in
nature to where
something like a drone can turn into a
queen through other means you know so I
thought that was a good idea to include
that that I think it should have been
kind of like that from the beginning and
then they introduced the queen alien
later on that bit that'll work too
yeah but no I could kind of see you know
there might be a circumstance where
there's only one drone alien and it has
to reproduce there's no Queens around so
it has you know a way to kind of become
a false queen or to make eggs and it
makes egg and out of that egg comes a
queen or it comes you know might be
standing like that happens in that it
happens in the insect world have that
kind of like Michael so that's not crazy
so something we have at some fans I
think get mad oh no that alien can't do
that like they're gonna dictate what
that what what the xenomorph can do ya
know which I kind of wish like Ridley
Scott or Dan yeah nobody could just call
these people up specifically no don't
tell me what my [ __ ] alien yeah life
life finds a way oh you know even the
Jeff Goldblum sedinger yeah even snakes
can sometimes change sexes if they're
some fish can do this with your aren't
enough room if there's too much of a
sexual imbalance yeah they can become
another gender so they so the species
can continue yes and so it makes sense
that maybe something kind of like an ant
or a highly-evolved be an Alien Ant or
an alien bee or whatever you might want
to call this thing however we want to
look at it it might have the ability to
produce a queen by transforming a person
into an egg yeah it has a queen in it or
something like that yeah exactly I
thought was cool now let's talk a little
bit about I was gonna say now the one
the first alien came out in 1979 it was
mostly positively reviewed it was
actually nominated for a bunch of awards
a bunch Saturn Awards BAFTA Awards it
was actually nominated for an Academy
Award for Best Visual Effects or
something like that um you know some
critics didn't like it but then kind of
reassessed later on because it's obvious
was it was a classic if I had to pick I
would actually I actually like alien a
little bit better than aliens just
because it's more a straight up
I like the darkness I like the
suspenseful nasai
the relatability the characters I like
like the regular Joe type characters
just kind of doing their job and then
getting [ __ ] up by one alien but then
came a Lian's 1986 now this was actually
not directed by Ridley Scott obviously
it was directed by James Cameron yeah
and he was I don't believe he was the
first choice but after the executives
read his script for the Terminator and
they thought he would be a good one to
do this because and initially they were
planning to do an alien sequel not that
long after the first one but then you
know there was some stuff with the
studio it's like well it didn't really
make enough money that warrant a sequel
and blah blah blah but eventually they
got around to making one in 1986 now
aliens was actually much more like it
still had some horror elements but I
would call it a sci-fi action movie yeah
I saw her than anything else I saw this
one new in the theater when it came out
I can remember in a video of being in a
video arcade in a mall called Aladdin's
castle and I had two aliens all right
waiting for Showtime to go in there and
see it yeah I think I was playing that
art Knopf or some no is
sullivo some video game that we had and
I was just dying to see this movie and
it scared me so much my when I saw alien
1 with my dad yeah afterwards you know I
get back in the truck and he's driving
and I'm back I'm being kind of quiet he
goes scared you did this yeah yeah ok
let's see it again
let's see it again next week and so
alien wanted made a big impression on me
so waiting to see alien - you know it
was just like on pins and needles and
the sensation I had at that time in what
you say it was 81 86 86 yeah when when
this move story starts unfolding and I'm
finding out that all of those eggs got
exposed and that there's got to be
hundreds of those things out there I was
sucking terrified I was like I tell ya
like one's bad and yeah yeah
first movie she had to blow up the whole
pump yeah yeah just to get rid of rock
an alien water everything right cuz you
know that the alien to me was kind of
like Jason imagine one day it's bad
enough you got thousands of them no no
Jason Club yeah
I really wasn't aware that I wouldn't
know where at the time watching the
movie that it was an action movie even
though action was unfolding yeah I
didn't really see it as an action movie
I just saw it as a horror movie with a
bunch of horrible monsters and these
Marines fighting them yeah it wasn't
till after we you know I mean yes you
start cooling off you go yeah it was an
action movie wasn't it yeah I see what
you're saying though it's seem more like
just an over-the-top horror movie at the
time did it seem like terrifying yeah
cuz cuz I'm putting myself in the
position as these people you know yeah I
got guns now I'm gonna get you you know
I'm you know you know fight them you
know that kind of stuff because before
they didn't really have any effective
weapons well yeah cuz they weren't
expecting
we're just on their way back to earth
right it was a just got rerouted without
without any of their own I mean they did
yeah you said you liked alien one first
better than alien 2 I lived it as they
came out in Psalm in the theatres at the
time I would say alien 2 blue alien 1
away a lot of people say that that it's
like the the sequel that you know that
is way better than the original which
doesn't usually happen I wouldn't say it
was way better in that way though well
it was as they couldn't redo alien 1 and
he didn't want to hear James Cameron he
wanted to approach it from a different
perspective that was done already yeah
you couldn't have another horror movie
with one alien and it run around killing
people that wouldn't work anymore yeah
you had to up the ante you had you had
to know more about the aliens where they
come from you have we had you had to
know an alien to delivered yeah it
actually delivered it was one of the
first times I go into a movie
Hollywood is rocking at this time I mean
they knew how to handle a franchise at
this at this particular time you know
they they didn't do too well with three
but you know I know the history of the
movie they did the best they could
I respect three but it didn't top to two
was just rolling
I mean it was awesome really good and in
other franchises you know what was going
on was you know Indiana Jones Temple of
Doom yeah and then later on t2 came so
in those days
sequels sometimes could be as good or
better than the original yeah it does
happen every now it wasn't a sustainable
wobble Hollywood started to [ __ ] up
after that yes well then the thing is
once you get into I mean even even a
premise as seemingly wide-ranging as
aliens it's like you're gonna get into
some repetitiveness and you know things
of that nature it's just gonna has just
the nature of the beast but honestly
when aliens came out I mean it was
immediately like the critics were just
like orgasmic and how [ __ ] wonderful
this movie was and it was nominated for
pretty much all the awards it was
nominated for tons and tons of Academy
Awards interestingly and I didn't know
this until I just read it on the
Wikipedia page Sigourney Weaver was
nominated for Best Actress for this
movie it was her first nomination she
didn't win but it was actually that's a
really big deal it was 1986
I mean sci-fi and horror was still kind
of a kind of iffy genre I got to mention
something though alright and this is
some personal experience alien to the
success of alien 2 really was predicated
on whether or not you had seen alien 1
yeah because I had can't I came out of
seeing alien 2 and I was blown away and
saw a girl that I knew waiting to go in
and see it and she goes was then he goes
that [ __ ] was scary man yeah well later
on I saw her again she cuz this [ __ ]
wasn't scary and I said did you see
alien once because now so if you didn't
see alien aliens didn't scare you that
much because it was because you didn't
go through the experience of being
terrified by one just by just one of
them right so you didn't have the
backstory yeah there was something about
you were terrified by one of them and
then I was telling there were thousands
of them and you were seeing them
fighting against a group of people that
were prepared right you know I mean even
though the whole premise
to the movie and one thing that I do
love about aliens is the development of
Ripley's character because she's kind of
like given a lot more depth I mean she
has a lot of depth than the first movie
- but her characters there's really
expanded out like especially through her
relationship with the Marines and our
relationship with Newt the little girl
that they find and it's just this really
really cool like expansion of her
character and like I said she was
nominated for Best Actress
that year but um you know here's a thing
where the beginning of the movie is her
trying to tell them about this alien
that she ended up having to blow up the
Nostromo the ship ya need he believed
and they didn't believe her so with you
know I remember when I was first seen
that for the first time I'm like whoa
they don't believe her
oh man what [ __ ] yeah and then I
said you know I was I was still young
and I was going like yeah maybe they
wouldn't believe you you know yeah
because you know when you're optimistic
when you're a kid you think yeah yeah
we've been possessed I survived
and then you get all the company hey
it's over here you know you wouldn't
even cross your mind that they wouldn't
believe you yeah it's probably crossed
her mind but she probably you got very
very upset and I don't blame her but
then later you know they come crying
back to her they're like oh well the the
colony that was that you know we sent
there over the ensuing 57 years that she
was in cryosleep yeah you know oh they
haven't been responding so maybe there's
something to that alien thing that
you've been telling us about so why
don't you just go back up there and
check that out at least I mean at least
they did send all the Marines up there
with it but here's the thing though they
sent all the Marines up there ostensibly
and yeah all eight of them her going she
even said to Paul Reiser's character
yeah who was the [ __ ] he loved this
movie she's like you know I will go if
you promise that we are going to wipe
these aliens out and he was like yeah
sure we're totally gonna do that yeah
you know yeah you know how that [ __ ] go
you know how the whole weyland-yutani
Corp yeah thank you just want to go
we're gonna wipe them out for sure no
really yeah and the only scent what they
only said what one squad or one platoon
you know which about eight nine guys
yeah it was nothing like yeah and the
lieutenant that was leading them was
brand new he's only been out there's
only his second combat mission you know
so a real high priority mission they
sent just you know one platoon or a
squad whatever they want to call it
feeling and then a green you know as you
know as a set up it had to be like I
said and I think we mentioned this 200
Prometheus review it's like you know
because so many people complained why
we're all the scientists idiots and all
this other concepts oh yeah and I think
the same thing was happening they don't
say it but I think it's implied that
even though yeah they sent these kind of
badass you know Space Marines and
everything up there ostensibly to check
out what had happened there weren't that
many of them and also sent everybody who
knew about this alien anyone who
survived and knew about them they all
sent him there oh yeah
so I'm Nessen like even from the
beginning their whole thing yeah it's
and why were they so keen to make Ripley
go along with them right and though she
had been traumatized for trying to kill
all witnesses yeah they're trying to
kill them all off and bring back the
[ __ ] aliens so they can use the wrong
weapons and [ __ ] like that
so I think that was kind of their plan
from the beginning and that's why they
sent that [ __ ] Paul Reiser to kind of
you know facilitate people were going on
about you know how awesome the Space
Marines were you know I'm ex infantry
you know and I'm telling you those guys
with shitty soldiers most of them you
know yeah that's why they got their
asses kicked
well they had a lot of [ __ ] that was
wrong Cameron was saying that he liked
the whole thing where he's like you had
these Marines and they were like super
cocky and they're like we're gonna kick
all this we have all this firepower come
on bring it but I'm done then they were
like oh [ __ ] yeah oh Christ he's like so
he kind of like that juxtaposition and
the Corporal was the only one that had
the right idea he heard Ruby civilian
nuclear side from orbit
nukes I'm orbit yeah that was the same
as watching brings him yeah you know
well like I said that was like the cool
thing about his character so he's the
underdog guy figures it out well and it
seems like too that the whole I mean the
whole arc of Ripley's character at least
through the first two movies was almost
just kind of like a struggle to get her
[ __ ] voice heard even though she's
only one that's right in all of these
[ __ ] movies and it's like pulling
teeth to get some dude to agree with her
well today would you please listen to
her that's because the other guy the
guys had ulterior motives yeah yeah yeah
they want to bring the thing back alive
or you know they're following company
orders that say bring the thing back
alive you know stuff like that yeah
there's all kind of yeah yeah right
answer wasn't the answer they wanted to
hear right exactly yeah yeah exactly but
yeah I feel like and and like I said I
think Sigourney Weaver is like amazing
in this and Ripley is really what the
most one of the most iconic horror
sci-fi action movie characters ever I
mean you know what I mean I don't think
anyone's gonna dispute that but I mean
like I said I love both of these movies
I love aliens but I'm gonna give the
edge to alien even though they're really
not the same kind of movie I mean
obviously they're two different
directors James Cameron did a phenomenal
job it's an amazing movie it just like
keeps you on the edge of your seat the
whole time
but because I'm more a horror person I
tend to you know if I'm better rewatch
one I'll probably watch the first one
just because it's so creepy they he
doesn't show the alien much it's just
kind of like in the shadows all the time
and it's like super spooky it's almost
like a haunted house type of movie yeah
and you know I just prefer that type of
thing but like I said the second one is
also a masterpiece and I'm not gonna
fight anybody over that and alien 3 is
not a bad movie no it's not ID is good
the tone of the movie is good the
problem with movies is cop pointless
they kill off two characters from from
alien 2 that they didn't have to kill
off actually three wouldn't it cuz it
was the robot Hicks and a little girl
that killed before you know they're not
even there yeah they're there killed off
in a crash it ends up on a prison planet
and really the way that movie ends it
makes the whole thing kind of pointless
like so what you know and then alien 4
is kind of a cartoonish yeah movie not
horrible but I would say not are not
artistically great really not deep
either I'm not I mean
especially when the first two are that
good yeah I mean anything you do is
gonna seem like a pail yeah and like I
said I'm gonna get a lot of hate for it
but Prometheus and covenant or fall more
closely in line with one and two then
three and four and I like two Prometheus
and a Lincoln yeah yeah I think there's
a generational differences it seems like
some really young people really hate
Prometheus they really hate covenant and
I think just because there's different
audience expectations nowadays I think
yeah it's yeah but they expect a movie
to be I think is not exactly what people
of our generation expected they want
everything answered for them very easily
you know and they want things to lay out
real perfectly with any kind of expanded
universe literature that they've been
reading and it all has to fit in an
interlock and if it doesn't fit in with
their video games that they've been
watching in the fan fiction that they've
been reading then they reject it which
you know the problem and it's a problem
with fandom I guess you could say yeah I
mean you know it that might have been
like that the whole time but you just
hear about it market yeah well I say
well Prometheus doesn't make sense and
they go well yeah it does make sense
it's just not making the sense that you
want to me yeah all the crew was
incompetent but they were incompetent on
purpose you know the companies you know
the the company sent them there
yeah to fail yeah that kind of stuff it
was actually the replicant that did it
you know what was her name
the blonde hair miss Vickers yeah yes
yeah miss Vickers is a replicant and
then you find that out a few you know if
you buy the blu-ray and look at the
expanded material on there there's a
bunch of little things is trying to tie
in with the new Blade Runner movie too
but I have to say that even after all
this time I mean the first alien which
was made in 1979 for [ __ ] sake
it still looks amazing yeah that's good
the inside of the spaceship yeah there's
like you know big buttons and stuff like
that but it's not as egregious as some
of it has that same used future kind of
that Star Wars has which actually makes
it kind of ageless yeah because it looks
like just old ramshackle kind of this is
our old towing spaceship and I kind of
shitty looking I probably put it up
there with 2001 yeah and it was
definitely inspired by that also just
like on a new taller version of mm yeah
that's a good way of putting it and and
obviously the creature design like I
said that has not been topped in all the
years since that is just an amazing
amazing monster and you know that's
that's all gigger right there that yeah
somebody said some might say that the
predator was also a good design there
were a lot of good designs yeah yeah
it's just uh that was a badass that was
the first believable monster I had seen
in a movie yeah now you know haven't
lived through all this yet when they
went all the stuff was new that one
scared me
but I think the thing scared me more
yeah the whole idea that that thing
could get in India and absorb absorb you
and make a copy of you and replicate
itself that way and if it got out and it
made it back to the civilization could
swallow up the earth there's swallow
swallow up the Earth's population in
about three or four years I think you
think's what the computer said that blew
my mind to really like the thing and
also that knew the the 2009 thing wasn't
bad either thing was 2009 yeah actually
quite like yeah the prequel I know some
people didn't like it but I actually
kind of liked it but the thing well the
thing about the thing is that it's kind
of hard to make anything scarier than
this person that you know and you think
is your best friend or your wife or your
husband I think whatever is an alien and
you can't tell that's kind of that's why
invasion of the body snatchers is scary
yeah it's the same premise and it's
weird cuz it's like an alien colony and
it can make any kind of appendage it
needs it can become a spider and fall
apart into a bunch of pieces it's blood
can run away but you turn into a big B
stick it does whatever it wants as far
as like straight-up monster movies go
it's hard to get scarier than alien
because that is a [ __ ] frightening
looking and actually interestingly
enough the first the first alien 1979
the guy inside that suit was a dude that
they just found at a bar this night
girion guy it was six foot ten and he
was really really skinny he had these
really really long arms and they wanted
that guy for the suit because they were
like we want it to look like he's like
obviously we wanted to be a suit we
wanted to be a practical effect but we
want it to look like there's no way that
there could be a human in there you know
they they actually did find a good fine
egami some sometimes it stunt people and
stuff but he was generally there's a
deleted scene where he creeps in and
starts messing around and kind of
flirting with one of the women before he
kills him it's on that DVD they didn't
put it in there but kind of weird yeah
he was sitting there on the ground and
unfolding and stuff it's weird
yes supposed to be kind you know like a
rape monster yeah that's a rape monster
well that's what it was yeah a rapist
monster yeah and originally ovipositor
yeah originally he was gonna be real
interested in girls it's kind of cool
kind of weird when you think about it
yeah but uh yeah okay so anything else
you want to add and like I said we have
the movies that you have yeah this and
there's something wrong with you yeah I
really don't know help you and there's
actually a lot of movies in that line
but alien and aliens I mean if you
haven't seen that you've seen these
number ology like how are you how do you
live you're not living correctly just
ghostly if you haven't seen the thing
well that too yeah I mean you know both
of them actually you're good and yeah we
have the really rays of both of these
like I said we have the whole set aliens
has the has an extended cut and the
theatrical cut actually on aliens I
think I prefer the theatrical cut just
because it seems like um you know the
director's cut is quite long it's like
two and a half hours in it and there's
extra stuff of Hudson that kind of
diminished his character I think he's a
little too goofy yeah and the extended
cut and this theatrical cut you can take
him a little more seriously yeah yeah
that's so yeah but you know and for the
first alien I actually prefer the
director's cut it's not a huge
difference there's just like a couple
brief scenes that have been added back
in and I actually think they enhance the
movie quite a bit you know so but it's
that's going to be up to people's
opinion I'm not
yeah no thing but I guess that will wrap
it up for our discussion of alien and
aliens so you guys Rock see you guys
around and also remember if you liked
the show to like share subscribe on all
your social media if you'd like to
financially support the show you can go
to our patreon page which is patreon
comm
you can go to our blog which is 13
o'clock podcast wordpress.com and
there's a link in the sidebar to a
PayPal account if you'd like to give a
one-time donation also be sure to check
out our Zazzle store at zazzle.com slash
13 o'clock we have t-shirts and a tote
bag if you'd like to purchase one also
remember that our regular episodes go up
every Tuesday and our movie reviews go
up every Friday we will see you next
time bye